juste envie de dire par rapport au
principe de finale mais vous êtes pour
ou contre des soubresauts moi je suis
complètement contre alors un cas je vais
vous dire pourquoi je suis content en
fait je trouve que ce qu'ils font est
absolument génial et derrière je trouve
très courageuse mademoiselle devenir ce
soir le le dis en fait en gros ça
s'appelle de l'agit-prop l'agit-prop
c'est en fait se servir des médias pour
alerter l'opinion publique sur un
problème en l'occurrence le dans le cas
de ce que vous avez fait c'est d'un
ajout aux puits dans le cadre d' avant
une frontière mal gardée et sert qu'on
fait parce qu ils sont là on va coûter
pour regarder cette frontière et 10
rebonds en effet n'y a pas de forces de
police donc il ya des migrants qui passe
et c est ce que vous allez bientôt ça va
être des résistants c'est vous dites à
tous les gens qui lui sont reprochés
d'invités tailler des scuds fonds porte
parole de générations ayant des chiens
la presse je vois bien pourquoi pourquoi
il ya eu un tel mouvement et untel ou
unetelle levé boucle passe que déjà avec
nous les gens connaissent pas tellement
leur action nice qui sont parce que moi
j'entends des trucs néonazis extrême
droite et toute façon on entend mais ne
maîtrisons pas mon moi je suis pas
d'accord avec ça moi je les clichés sur
les emplois c'est une sorte de barre à
mine il dit se bat à réserver aux gens
de race blanche mais c'est moi j'appelle
ça du racisme ce que je suis on me
remercient de ces raisons monsieur a
raison on ne connaît pas assez et thalys
paris veut sur le site de génération
précaire où il ya une boutique on
souhaite joyeux bric et le stylo tout ça
est très sympathique parce que quand
même faut faire du business familial
hélicoptères ont comme au ps faut payer
les troubles et les hélicoptères aux
noms sensibles quoi l'état les gens mais
je vois qu il m quelles sont nos
principes nos valeurs donc je vais
regarder ça m'intéressait enfin c'est le
courage sa part dont il loue le courage
à aller à 40,50 agressé un type qui à
marcher des heures et des heures dans la
neige pour fuir la guerre ou la mise
jusqu'au fond du court c'est le nom du
cndd syrie mais la met la france en
france il y des gens courageux il ya des
gens qui ont résisté à des oppresseurs
ces gens qui auraient sinon si on veut
pas dire mais c'est insulter les mêmes
attentes des abonnés d'al qaïda tend des
fuites les gens qui ont dit y a des gens
de suite
ces dirigeants qui sont engagés dans des
causes humanitaires vont essayer je suis
vous allez dire que c'est courageux
nathalie dans la neige cui cui qui les
gens qui les migrants qui arrivent de
l'espagne que l'on sache pas les
messages à l'espagne et l'on sait qu'ils
sont en espagne l'espagne francona pas
ressuscité il n'y a pas eu un
bombardement de l'armée soit ils sont en
espèces les vaudois cabinet me remets ce
soir dit des conneries attendait iman et
sur le tri nations raisonnement ils sont
en espagne d'accord ils sont arrivés en
espagne qui doivent présenter un dossier
si ebel si ici on où il s'installe et on
et ça ils sont arrivés en espagne qui
doivent présenter un dossier d'asile en
espagne s'ils fuient vers la france
c'est soit qu'ils ont été déboutés soit
parce que le shopping de l'asile et plus
farouches fini juste que je vous avais
dit encore une fois une chose faute vous
vous dites fausse vous dites ils vont
agresser un pauvre migrants qui est en
train de traverser la frontière
pardon mais à ma connaissance ces gens
là n'ont jamais agressé un million à ma
connaissance pour l'un à ma connaissance
pour l'instant ces gens là n'ont jamais
fait quelque chose d'illégal j'ai
l'accord ils ont non non ils nous
attendent pas leur offrir
mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'elle
est à 40 menacer quelqu'un c'est pas du
jeu
des milliers je ne voulais pas donner
jouer ensemble et la terre est cher
monsieur je ne peux débattre avec des
gens qui disent la vérité
vous avez parlé d'agression il n'y a pas
eu d'agression par ailleurs ce qu'ils
ont fait ce qu'ils ont fait n'est pas
illégal parce que ils ont été attaqués
en justice et à ma connaissance ils
n'ont pas été condamnés si j'ai une wii
si je termine juste je suis partant du
temps merci séminaire 10 est gentil ce
que je jouais juste dire c'est que ça
s'appelle de l'agit-prop l'agit-prop ça
consiste à agiter un chiffon devant les
médias pour dire regardez là il ya un
problème
et d'ailleurs ils ont réussi parce qu'on
aurait à en parler et à chaque fois
qu'ils font une action on en parle aussi
moi ça me fait deux fois je termine moi
ça me je trouve que c'est très bien vu
dans la cité dans laquelle on vit et par
ailleurs ce qui me fait marrer c'est que
aujourd'hui quand c'est des gens d'un
groupe de droite qu'ils font sur la
question de l'immigration ou de
l'islamisation
on est tous là hurler il faut tout de
suite se mettre à plat ventre en disant
c'est insupportable mais quand c'est
dans l'autre sens quand c'est cédric
héron qui fait passer des migrants et là
ils organisent le viol lui ils
organisent ils essaient d'utiliser à bon
escient le mot viol quand même pas
l'actualité ça serait quand même bien
des excuses il ya des gens qui disent la
loi n'est pas respectée donc on m'a t-il
attention la tude dans un autre des gens
qui ne parlent pas et qu raciste c'est
pas une opinion c'est dans une région où
il ya des gens dans le besoin